so your characters in the movie are
pretty competitive who's the most
competitive in real life I'm 100 percent
the most competitive to know good
question I guess we should have a fight
and I think we're all competitive
because I don't think we'd be doing this
job if we win hmm and I think that yeah
it's a good question
domi spoke a lot about the chemistry
reads with the three of you and how
important it was the cast three people
who really liked each other so can you
talk about the casting process we didn't
know at the start I think he's talking
about we got together in the hotel
almost like we hung out with us and the
younger counterparts and we all you know
had food a lot of times and then we all
told me we bring onset drinking and we
all bonded that way and you know we went
to the the bar which these boys would
drink at a hundred years ago the eagle
and child yes yes very cool so at the
end of the movie we get a shot of you
guys where you very much look like the
four hobbits so I want to ask what Lord
of the Rings characters do you think you
would be in real life mm-hmm Treebeard I
like him I like his bad dude
IV is Tom or as Christopher I know what
you think Tom would be yeah that's a bad
answer I think you would probably be
Boromir at his height when he's very
sure of himself and very confident for
the fall from grace okay
incredible no I just think it whatever
you say for me is gonna be better than
mine okay so I think you would probably
be eomer but after the events of lore of
the Rings when he calms down a little
bit and becomes the king I'm ready
you're three characters are obviously
very intertwine that's why you're here
speaking as one voice today what was it
like to build these roles together
instead of more traditionally maybe
going off and doing all that work on
your own well we kind of we used each
other for sure but also the younger
aspects of ourselves who were who were
there and we got to watch work a few
times on set and they definitely infused
our performance just by I was watching
them and seeing their little habits
their idiosyncrasies the way they spoke
that energy that they had in the group
because they were all so different each
for each one of the four was so
different and it was interesting for us
to sit back and watch that and go okay
well that's the role that my characters
play in this scenario so that would that
would progress into their later years
and what can I use from that to help me
with mine so it's big team effort yeah
and then the last thing that I like to
ask everyone is there a single moment or
scene that you want people to look out
for when they see the movie my umbrella
is actually in the box somewhere how
much oh good I hope someone watching
decides to make a gif of that we can
Bobby wonderful thanks so much guys
you